only problem I ever had with my daughter
is that she's been smarter than me since
she was
six and like half the time when we're
sitting in our living room I didn't
understand a word that was coming out of
her mouth like we you me in my living
room I'll be like what's up baby she's
like got Daddy
got it's like having a dolphin in my
living room right she came home one day
and she was like oh my god daddy I have
to tell you something so important oh my
god daddy okay Daddy Chris tried to kiss
me I told him I wasn't sure if I was
allowed to do that I had to go home and
ask my
daddy and I said you know what babe
thank you very much for asking look I
know you're a teenager and your hormones
are running crazy and my job as your
father is just to tell you what I know
and what I know is is
that God doesn't let little hookers into
heaven do whatever you want to do with
that information babe